from the post-millennial
multi-millionaire celebrity rain Wilson
slammed for smearing Oliver Anthony over
populist Anthem I don't know that he
really smeared him but uh boy do I love
this rain Wilson you guys know you know
him he was in the office yeah he played
Dwight Schrute that's right he said if I
were writing a song about rich men north
of Richmond I wouldn't talk about obese
people on welfare I'd sing about CEOs
who make 400 times their average
worker's salary up from 50 times 30
years ago and corporations that pay zero
taxes and offshore tax shelters for
billionaires let me just uh pause right
there and no one would listen to it so
rain Wilson you're an ultra Rich
Hollywood celebrity type
I don't think this song was written for
you I think this song was written for
the working class guy who's expressing
this discontent with a broken system and
guess what
if he wrote the song as you described it
I don't think it'd be number one I don't
think he'd have the biggest song in the
world right now I don't think he'd have
debuted as one of the only people ever
to debut on their first ever single
charting at number one clearly you are
wrong I think that uh Chris Anthony I'm
gonna call I'll call him Oliver Anthony
that's a stage name it's Chris lunford
is his actual name um but he mentions
the the bureaucrats in that song at some
point I don't remember
he also talks about people that are
getting obese on on welfare which is a
phenomenal point because people you can
buy Pepsi with food stamps you can buy
candy and chocolate crappy crappy
like that's so bad for people so so let
me just point this out when Oliver
Anthony says you know if you're five
foot three and 300 pounds taxes
shouldn't be buying your fudge rounds
rain Wilson doesn't get this he is the
fat
effeminate man with liberal
sensibilities who's advocating for lazy
individuals to leech off a system for
which the working class work and pay for
and it is the overall majority of them
who do it and when he says yes but if
the billionaires paid their taxes yes
well the billionaires paid their taxes
it would barely account for any of the
tax base this is the lie that crackpots
like rain Wilson and these other far
left extremists push to convince you to
allow them to gut the system and steal
from you it's the billionaires who are
at fault let's do the math you if you
were to tax I love this this meme if you
taxed every billionaire at 100 and took
all of their money it would account for
a very small percentage of the actual
tax expenditures and it would last you
only a few months yeah what really funds
the system is that if you've got 300
million people and you take a dollar
from them every day you get 300 million
dollars per day
so you're talking about a couple billion
dollars per week two points a mod you're
talking about billions per month it
doesn't matter how many how much in cash
the billionaires actually have most of
their billionaire assets are in hard
hard they're hard assets they can't
actually liquefy not easily so yeah no
Oliver Anthony is correct he's sitting
there saying his paycheck is almost
nothing the Dollar's worthless and
there's some five foot three 300 pound
person eating fudge rounds off of his
hard work and labor and then Rayne
Wilson's like why aren't you complaining
about billionaires bro rain you are
exactly what you describe yeah
it's the ritual the problem yes you
ultra wealthy fat liberals voting to to
gut the salaries and the and the and the
payments of the working class to then
promise to ignorant lazy people that if
they keep voting for you give them free
stuff yeah
it's a while to see people like Hassan
talking about what do you want to
talk about yeah see him say this stuff
he says and he's in a mansion in LA it's
like dude come on yeah I I think that
Oliver Anthony makes a phenomenal Point
talking about these people that are sick
on welfare not and maybe he's annoyed
that he's paying for it but also if
we're gonna fix Society it's gonna be
from the ground up and if people at the
ground are sick then they're not going
to be able to fix Society so it's a big
problem eat healthy get your mind right
get your family right then get your your
Society right it's a system that
perpetuates itself though imagine being
on welfare again making eating food that
makes you sick you're then become
dependent on the like the Health Care
system I mean it's the whole I don't
know it ripples out so and then when
they want to thank you someone I don't
know how literal that is so much as like
it seems to me like a metaphor again I
haven't listened to the song though so
oh you haven't heard it yet no I mean
it's fine it's short it's like three
minutes two two and a half minutes long
or three minutes I uh I still think it's
weird that he's like if I were gonna
write a song I would write
if I was going to be in a comedy it
would be way better than I would have
looked in a different direction than you
looked rain in that one scene when you
were talking to Jim I would look to the
left and yeah your posture was good but
it wasn't that good I would add a little
bit better posture I'm just kidding me
get out here help me make this movie bro
and get work it out with Tim because I
love you Ray come on your spirit man
let's do this I think a lot of people
have affection for wearing Wilson
because he was sort of unusual his his
character on the office is uh such a big
deal and so interesting and then he
himself has kind of an unusual life but
this like well if I had written a song I
would have attacked someone else and
therefore you're as bad like obviously
this song is popular in hitting a chord
and if you want to write a different
song great do it but don't tear down at
the points that he's making out are
resonating with people in fact humble
yourself and take away that people are
really feeling a connection to this
maybe you are not aware of something
that you should open your eyes to I
think you know what he's uh he's playing
at Blue Ridge rock festival oh I think
we went there last year that's a great
Festival that was one of the best I've
ever been to oh those stages are awesome
slip knot or not slip not sorry um Gwar
guar played Adeline Jack Black and Kyle
Gas Tenacious D yeah of course Adelita
sway they had us got us backstage they
tweeted out special guest Oliver Anthony
man oh that's gonna be lit we should go
when he's gonna have he's gonna have
like
when he plays that's gonna have the
biggest crowd I hope the headline that
because that'll be really good wow does
he have a full band now I I guess he's
gotta gotta whip the band together put
out a statement that was like I am very
excited about this thank you very much
for also I don't feel like I'm quite a
good enough musician to like take on all
these things like there's an element
that he's trying to like deliver at a
maximum level to people who are
supporting him same thing with
merchandise too he put out a tweet that
essentially said I want to do things
right I don't want to just go to chop
shop so be patient and he's working with
like a small family owned or like a
local company yeah yeah the music it
will stay on the test of time so there's
no rush yeah it's cool although the iron
is you're not right now so it's good to
hit it you don't need to be the best
musician ever this is the biggest
mistake I hear from young musicians that
I've experienced in my life and it
actually translates to almost every
industry yeah so when I was younger I
played a show I played a bunch of shows
played a lot of shows actually and uh
I'm I was like middle middle of the
middle lineup whoever it's called I was
in the headliner I was in the opening
act and I had the room packed it was
like a 150 seats or whatever
I ended up making a couple hundred bucks
I was super excited I was like Wow most
of the songs that I wrote were just like
four chords relatively basic and then I
would sing
the headlining performance was one of
the most musically beautiful songs I've
ever heard and people left the room
yeah and the reason is it's what we call
music for musicians Oliver Anthony wrote
music for people and people want to hear
that music and then you get these
musical theorists who are like here's
how you write a good song because
they're trying to impress musicians
that's cool no by all means like make
the best music ever made arpeggio the
guitar
like really cool stuff and really great
lyrics that are really impactful or
write a song for the masses that the
regular people resonate with that speaks
to them and you are exactly what a good
musician is I'll put it this way the
best ice cream in the world what does
that mean does it mean like you should
consume it because it's good for you or
does it mean it tastes great
because it's what I was always I would
always tell my friends I knew a guy
played in a band it was like weird
experimental stuff and he kept talking
about how big it was going to be and I
was like you know do your thing man but
I'm just gonna tell you you're making
like you're making like you know
asparagus ice cream
some people may really really like
asparagus item it's experimental man
we've never seen this before most people
just want chocolate you know so figure
out what that Mass Appeal is if you're
trying to be a famous musician if you're
just trying to be a musician because you
like music and you like the art more
power to you but don't act like you're
gonna be the biggest so this is what I
would say to Oliver Anthony man you are
the best musician because you wrote a
song that people want to hear it's all
matters it's also the ways things that
you mentioned resonation like if it
resonates and that's literal vibrational
resonance that your voice produces in
other human beings like you vibrate
their bones when they say that song
resonated with me it's because it
actually literally produced resonation
so the voice I mean it's so lost in the
Modern Age unfortunately I want it to be
recovered this text communication crap I
mean it's you want to talk about where
why is there a degradation in society in
any way I think it stems from that
people are texting each other what 30
years ago we would only speak to each
other about so you could resonate there
was phone but I and and the phone loses
a little bit but I I agree with you I
think the internet has destroyed
community and particular text chat yes
right with Twitter and short text too
because people in I love this TMZ I
think it was DMZ now somebody wrote an
article where they were like Kid Rock is
slammed might have been Newsweek uh over
drinking Bud Light and like with some
even claiming it was treason and then
they showed my tweet of all caps treason
which was clearly sarcasm but no Tim
you're always right over there they
don't care that it's sarcasm no they're
just like wow we can we can sell this
fake outrage any anybody who did a
modicum a a small amount of research
into my tweets and histories knows that
I did not literally think like there's I
don't care Kid Rock drank this thing
if Rayne Wilson had been able to say the
words of what he typed if there's a way
that I would understand what he was
saying and be like no I get it I get
what you're saying yeah and it would
even be inspirational for Oliver Anthony
to hear him say those words out loud
when in text it just looked like whiny
text I think text can be sort of
just corruptive to the weight flow or
you know intonation would yeah exactly
would would deliver a message I will say
in defensive writing there are times in
our history where we've relied on like
letters and written communication and
because you knew that you wouldn't get
the speed that we now have you put a lot
more thought into it right like think of
like some of the best love letters
written of all written of all time or
poetry or or things that we did in the
past I mean even like the Federalist
Papers right people spent time thinking
about what they were writing in a way
that we don't do now because everything
is so fast not that Twitter can't be
incredibly effective for delivering
messages uh but it's just a different
approach to something that we have
become accustomed to I was uh chatting
with my girlfriend uh and there was a
day that we were having just kind of a
subtle argument or whatever and we were
texting and I normally will not text
anything if there's a problem
emotionally it's verbal or we just I'll
peacefully you know I'll wait until I
see you and talk to you about it
um but anyway we typed and then like
days went by things were resolved and I
went back in that chat and for whatever
reason I saw the old messages and it
started to work me up again like it it
out of context it was the past it has no
place in my memory anymore we already
resolved it but it's still there in text
and I'm like reading it and thinking
like oh did she mean that when she typed
it well and these other emotions I'm
like what am I doing you've resolved the
argument you have to let it go yeah it
should have been like like a memory of a
communication it should be gone in my
memory now but because it's literally in
text I still have a copy of it that's
unnecessary and probably very very bad
for brain I've heard other couples say
that when they have a problem they like
to I knew this one couple that would
email each other and be like when I talk
to you face to face I'm kind of
dominated by my emotions so when I can
sit down and write you a thoughtful and
respectful email about whatever's
bothering me I actually find it easier
to resolve I I think that uh there's a
place for both but I think we are going
for speed and therefore stripping away a
kind of specific and descriptive
language which helps us understand what
the message is behind our written word
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time